[Music]
gene starts off this hour in cincinnati
ohio hi gene welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
so um
you should also say you help people
clean up messes because i have one um
so
um my ex-husband and i um 16 years ago
um
bought a house in our name
um for my son and his wife and their
three children we he's our only child
and um we did that because um their
credit was not good at the time and
they were busting up themes in one room
one bedroom i should say
and so
the agreement was they were to clean up
their credit and get the house out of
our name in five years and that was 16
years ago that was 16 years ago and
and my husband and i were married at the
time we found my ex-husband
so that's problem one
um
problem two um is
that skip forward they now have four
kids
um where i'm remarried he's remarried
and um
he is 70 and i'm mid-60s he is not in
the best of health
and
i have my health issues and so
um my
son and daughter-in-law mentioned
the other day that they were concerned i
didn't i didn't know that my ex-husband
had health issues but they mentioned the
other day that he does and they're
concerned
this was their concern that if something
happened um the ex-wife has several
children what would happen if the house
was still in his name yeah so maybe they
ought to do something about it after 16
months right but they still can't their
credit is still really bad
and
um and then the amount and of course the
market is as
good as it is has ever been and so
um the house on paper has gone up
dramatically in value
um
this could not this question couldn't
happen in a worse time but
so
the problem now is
getting out of there out of our names
and they don't have the credit where
they could go get a loan
um and i assume that you still owe on
the house
right and the other part of that
agreement was
that they would make all the house
payments and we never up whatever the
house payment was
they made it and we rolled everything in
together my husband and i have
ex-husband
um had really good credit i still do i
don't know what my ex is
cert circumstances so what are you all
gonna do
well that's what i'm calling for so
here's what my my husband and i
my current husband and i
um
were talking about um
so i could afford i could take it out of
my um retirement savings and just
we owe less than thirty thousand on it
um
the house probably is valued over a
hundred plus i don't really don't know
what it would be valued at with this
market
but um i could i could pay it off but
the question is
how do we transfer to them without
any gift tax um i don't know how do you
what is your net worth
my husband and i
um
probably a few million okay all right so
you want to give them another 30 000 and
just deed it to them
and you think your ex will deed it to
them
well that was the agreement to begin
with i know but willie if you do this
the agreement to begin with was they
paid off in five years it's been 16. so
nobody's done what they were supposed to
do yet this whole deal absolutely true
but my my ex-husband and i you know
we've tried to do the right thing by
them
whether they did the right thing or not
yeah and
um and again it kind of upset me because
her concern wasn't
you know oh he's in bad health my
concern too is
he his financial picture isn't good if
he ended up being nursing you have any
contact with him at all
um limited okay
all right here's the thing
i don't have a problem with uh you
paying off thirty thousand dollars
and right and signing the deed and you
can get in touch with your estate
planner
and file a uh unified estate tax credit
filing use up some of your estate uh
exemption your federal estate exemption
to avoid gift tax so you can do this
without any harm to you and you're
giving them 30 000 bucks the whole thing
smells really bad because your son is a
complete parasite he's done a horrible
job of managing his life and honoring
his mother
but you're gonna do it anyway and so
this and this cleans it up and it's done
i would not do all of that
and then your ex not deed his half
well
let me ask you this because i tried to
do research and then i thought i could
just call dave ramsey isn't it would he
be able to do a quick clean deed to me
no he'll get a he'll get a gift tax as
well
he has to deed it to whoever you can
both quit claim it to your son
your half to your son
and but it doesn't avoid gift x unless
you file
a form
file called the unified estate
tax credit write that phrase down both
you and your ex are gonna do this
because you're giving him a gift that is
larger than fifteen thousand dollars and
you're gonna get taxed fifty five
percent on it if you do without filing
this form so you need to talk to your
cpa tax attorney estate tax planner
whoever's doing this stuff for you
and it's it's not a hard thing to do but
it's very
it's very easy but uh a one-page quit a
one-page quit claim deed and a unified
estate tax credit by both you and your
ex and a thirty thousand dollar check to
the mortgage company and this deal's
over your son owns the house
quick claim deed
both of us
[Music]
both of us need to file a unified
estate
tax credit
okay
and pay off the debt of thirty thousand
dollars
but if you give him your half
and your ex doesn't
and his
new wife ends up owning this with your
son
it would be just desserts but it'd be
another mess
okay
i mean your son deserves a mess
because he is a mess
but there's no sense in creating one on
purpose so
i'd be in touch with your ex and try to
get it this all coordinated like a
little concert move here
you know okay for when when the one you
know the paperwork is the simplest part
of this whole thing it's all the
relational and financial implications
that worry me 16 years in the credit
still in the tank tells me he has not
been managing money well yeah and this
is not going to be a blessing to him but
but it does clean it up and for 30 grand
and you got several million in net worth
it's
a clean transaction
but it's kind of one it's not kind of it
is one you've got to hold your nose
while you do it
this is not really a blessing obviously
none of this has been a blessing to him
not going to feel the whole freaking
thing was a bad idea
16 years ago
11 years ago when you didn't call him on
it
and now
it was a bad idea the whole thing's a
bad idea there's nothing in that's as
good george the nicest
people
anywhere
are people who psychologists like dr
john deloney call
enablers
they are they cannot they see someone
who says i need help with this and they
just want to be helpful
even though when you look at it the help
is actually not help
it's actually harm
and so when you give a drunk a drink
the drunk is very happy with you
but you're not really helping you're
enabling
assisting in
their misbehavior that brings harm to
them it doesn't harm you yeah so if you
participate in someone's crazy and
assist them in it
because you're sweet
and almost all enablers are very sweet
people and i'm not being sarcastic they
are very kind they are so kind that they
cannot do the
hard work of
conflict for someone else's good
see when you call in here we love you so
much
we're gonna bust you
for your own good
it doesn't change the cost of the call
it's free
either way it it doesn't change that we
love you it doesn't change that we don't
love you it doesn't you know
and dave ramsey's tough no dave ramsey
loves you i want you to win so i'm going
to tell you the truth get out of the
street don't touch the hot stove you
know stay out stay away from these
things they bring you harm enablers on
the other hand participate our last
caller was an enabler
what i'm what i'm seeing here is
short-term help can lead to long-term
harm
that's what seems to be the pattern the
theme of all of these they're trying to
help in the short term because this
person can't do it on their own and
therefore we're going to give them a leg
up which is really going to hurt them
financially usually on this show in the
long term and usually relationally for
all parties involved long-term so if
your kid has bad credit
they can't hold down a job
they're not gonna get better by you
buying them a house
that simple hello
they're not it's not going to make their
life better
now if you need to buy groceries for
your grandbabies to eat do it
if you pay the light bill or something
occasionally that's up to you
but to the extent that you participate
in the mythology that they're not in
control of their life you are not being
a blessing to that point her son for 16
years
has never been able to recoup and put
his feet on the ground
after his mom and dad now divorced and
remarried both of them
bought him a house left it in both of
their names the house survived the
divorce
the home ownership survived the divorce
so they've been partners
with their ex
for 16 freaking years
how pleasant is this
and junior pays the bill
he can't get good credit but he seems to
pay this bill
this is like parent plus loan on
steroids when you're taking out a
mortgage for your kids so what would you
do in the alternative dave
well in the alternative i would
suggest that the young man rent
until he can get his crap together and
i'll be happy to pay him
pay for him to go to financial peace
university i'll pay for him to read a
book on money
from one of the many ramsey
personalities including me
i would uh even participate if if he
wanted to get out of debt and was on a
budget and was being real
gung ho i might even match him and say
for every thousand dollars you pay off
i'll pay a thousand for you
if you've got the money
and you want to help them get up and get
moving you're you're participating in
positive behaviors then that are going
to lead him to sustainability
not negative behaviors that allow him to
mask over and pretend like he doesn't
have a problem
and buying your kid a house and putting
it on a mortgage in your name is just
straight up stupid
never do that
under any circumstances
let them go rent something and if you
want to write some checks you know write
some checks and help them that way but
you don't need to get in the home
ownership business with an irresponsible
kiddo
it's a bad plan it doesn't work out well
for them or for you it ends up the way
her her situation ends up it's sad yeah
it's really science and we're all first
generation they really wanted to help
yeah and the problem is they defined the
word help wrong
and it wasn't real help instead of and
still look at them and going no
10 years from now you're still going to
be in a mess because you ain't going to
change until you change
you hadn't changed you know i mean it's
just that it's a mess yeah well it seems
like generosity you know we're big fans
of that around here absolutely if you're
generous in a way that doesn't help
someone get control of their life and
it's not a blessing to them then it
really wasn't generosity
even when you're being generous to a
charity
when you're giving to a charity that
mishandles money
all you're doing is participating in
their mishandling of the money
you just helped them do it
and so
you know we do
due diligence ramsey family foundation
before we give to charities we want to
make sure they're handling money well
that the money's actually going to help
the people it's not going to we don't
know how to run the office properly
and
some charities don't know how to run the
office property properly and they end up
spending 90 of the money on overhead and
10 to help the starving child or
whatever it is they're supposed to be
doing
you know and so it'd been easier just to
go feed some kids you know you'd have
been better off
and so you've got to use some good
common sense with this otherwise you're
participating and that is not being mean
and that's not being angry heartless
dave and it's not being heartless it's
not being tough
it's none of those things it's actual
love
i love you so much i'm not going to
participate in your misbehavior
i can't be a party to your misbehavior
because i love you too much
i will help you do positive things if
you want to do wonderful things i'm
going to walk with you i'll be your
biggest cheerleader i might even write
some checks in the positive direction
but i'm not going to mask over your
misbehavior and start paying for your
stuff
well as the saying goes you entertain a
clown you join the circus exactly and so
that's what people find themselves in is
now i'm in i'm all looped into this
crazy and now i have resentment because
it didn't work out how i thought it was
going to work out and now i'm calling
this show
and we have uh you know there's this
current generation coming up um
in the early 20s mid-20s
is uh has got two types of people in it
unbelievably responsible and mature
beyond their years
and ones that are still living in their
mother's basement at 27 years old
and uh moms
dads
kick them out
lovingly
give them a 90 day plan i'll walk with
you i'll coach you uh we're gonna assist
you
but playing uh playing nintendo is not a
job
playing call of duty is not a job
you need to go get a life
you're stunting your kids growth
emotionally by allowing them to exist in
your basement at 26 or 36 years old now
short term that's fine a safety net is
fine but a safety hammock is not a plan
we don't want a crutch yeah i mean
listen an eagle that doesn't leave the
nest is eventually known as a turkey
okay this is how this works
so these are these are enabling
situations you're not being helpful now
some people got kicked out of the house
in angry rage-filled ways or toxic
family situations and that's not what
i'm talking about i'm going to love you
so much i'll help you move the couch
i'm going to love you so much i'm going
to have taught you to work from the time
you were 5 years old until the time you
were 20 and then you actually know what
work looks like you know what a callous
is other than on your thumbs
you know and so you know it's just i'm
gonna love you so well that you are
sustainable as an adult and you will
have dignity long after i'm gone
and there's no dignity in being a
parasite no there's just none it doesn't
it doesn't it's not helpful to the
parasite even
we got to stop raising kids and start
raising adults that's what i'm seeing
out there you're right there's a lot of
great adults out there but there's a lot
of kids yeah and it's not a it's not
this generation every generation has
done it my generation had what they call
them the boomerangs you throw them out
and they come back
yeah
remember that one that's clever that was
good yeah oh man
gotta love it gotta love it
well we love you so much people we're on
your team we want you to win
and consequently we're gonna tell you
the truth might hurt your feelings
but it'll help it's entertaining radio
too this is the ramsey show